俺の名前は短パン小僧ポケモンマスターを
目指してマサラタウンにやってきたんだ
少年よ
頑張るんじゃぞありがとうございます絶対
にポケモンマスターになります
最初は全てが新鮮で楽しかった
[音楽]
[拍手]
行けカビゴンのしかかり
[音楽]
相棒のカビゴンとともにたくさん旅をして
たくさんの経験を積んだ
[音楽]
絶対ポケモンマスターになって君を幸せに
するあなたなら
必ずなれるわ
結婚してください
喜んでそして大事な嫁に子供だってできた
パパ
初めて
頑張ってらっしゃい
[音楽]
バイバイ
だがそんな幸せも長くは続かなかった
今日はポケモンいないし帰るか
[音楽]
あなたもうポケモンマスターはいいんじゃ
ない
娘の洋服費もあるしこのままだと
俺だって分かってるよ
お金を貸してください
[音楽]
[拍手]
今までありがとう
[音楽]
頑張ってポケモンマスターになってね
夢と現実とのギャップはあまりに大きかっ
た
今日からわしがパパじゃぞ
パパよろしくね
[音楽]
ポケモンマスターになるにはサトシを倒す
しかないそれからわしは数十年サトシを
待ち続けた6に飯も食わせられないで
ごめんなカビゴン
[音楽]
かかって来い
え
僕の名前は赤ピクミン今は土の中で育て
られてるけどいつか地上に出て幸せな生活
を送るんだ
シャワーの時間だ
[音楽]
ありがとう
[拍手]
[音楽]
地上はおいしい水以上最高の光何でも揃っ
てる
らしいよ私も早く地上に行ってみたいわー
早く
抜いてくれないかな
ついに地上に出られるぞやったこれ
受け取って
[音楽]
ありがとうそれじゃあまた地上で会おう
これが地上の神オリマー様は私は
[音楽]
ピクミンの声だ楽しそう
次は私が事情に出る番みたいTピクミン
どうしたの何でもない地上に出たら渡し
たいものがあるんだ
楽しみにしてるねいってらっしゃい
[音楽]
同じ生地は私たちが挙げた
地上に行ったら
告白するんだ
[音楽]
来たついに僕の番だ
[拍手]
[音楽]
僕の名前サンドバッグ君名前の通り
ハンドバッグのように殴られるのが仕事だ
[音楽]
ただいまあらおかえりなさい今日も
ボロボロねー
お父さんはこの仕事を楽しいのお父さんは
この仕事を誇りに思ってるよいつかあなた
にもわかる日が来るわ本当にわかるの
わかるさそれよりみんなご飯にしましょう
最初は全く理解ができなかった
理不尽にいた見つけられて何が楽しいんだ
大変よお父さんが救急車で運ばれたの
お父さんお父さん
[音楽]
息子よお前も立派なサンドバッグになるん
だぞ
[音楽]
そこから僕はお父さんの意思を受け継ぎ
下村くらいで
さ
サンドバッグ番号152番
出番そして
迎えた
初めての試合
何してんだほらだって
恐ろしさのあまり
逃げ出してしまった
もうこの仕事を続けたくないよ
今日も楽しかったちょっと待ってなんで君
そんなに楽しそうなの何でってだって僕
たちストレス解消の道具に使われてるだけ
だよそれは違うよ俺たちはプレイヤーと
ともに記録を作り上げてるんだ
有名なスポーツはどれも道具がなきゃ成立
しないサッカーだってバスケだって
野球だってボールがなきゃ成立しないだろ
それと同じこの競技もサンドバッグがい
ないと成立しないんだ僕はこの仕事を誇り
に思ってるよ
[音楽]
怖いけどやるしかない
僕は父親の衣装を受け継ぎ立派な
サンドバッグになるんだ
やっぱ無理
[音楽]
チャチャチャチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしく最初はチャンネル登録じゃんけん
ウルトラまたねー